- [Narrator] At Great Big Story,
we've been playing the
mobile game Clash of Clans.
Our favorite character is the balloon,
flown by skeleton who drops bombs
on enemies from above.
- [Voice On Radio] Welcome everyone to
Shreveport, Louisiana,
and the 2017 Red River Balloon Rally.
Over the coming days some of
the best hot air balloonists,
will be competing in the sky overhead.
- [Narrator] So we decided
to find someone who
drops things out of balloons in real life.
And we found this guy.
- My name is Rhett Heartsill,
and I am a competitive
hot air balloon pilot.
Competitive hot air ballooning is an
accuracy competition.
We have way points to fly into,
and we drop a marker,
and it's closest to that
way point is the best score.
My sister Kate, she
navigates to the targets,
driving on the ground.
She reads all the winds with
a little helium balloon,
‘cause we're usually coming
in from high altitude.
And we want to drop
down on the deck because
you're more accurate with
your throws from 50 feet high
than 500 feet high.
Absolutely.
The X's are only one meter by one meter.
So, a wizard tower would be
pretty simple to run through.
When you get down, you're
dead center over that X.
Your heart starts racing
like you have buck fever,
and that's what really makes it.
I was basically born into the sport,
and when you start that young,
it's just normal from day one.
My father's flown since the late ’70's.
When he bought a balloon, my
parent's didn't have any money,
but it turned out to be the best thing
that's ever happened to our family.
It's a good hobby to bring us together,
and we hope to continue
this as long as we can.